game for you tonight what was
the best part of this win
getting the win especially my
career man just seeing us
having a easy to keep fighting
you seen again ugly
down there coming down the
stretch but I would like to say
we just kept fighting man kept
fighting came out on top so
that's the best types of all
week you talked about you
personally talked about getting
Mike Williams more involved in
the offense and what
you think tonight did you guys
do a good job of that we did
a great job obviously, you see
how hungry is when nobody going
to stop in scoring a touchdown
and now that's just a fight he
has any man he's he's a big
playmaker and
he makes big plays happen
talk to my mom and let me tell
you about this life for a long
time as far as like I've been
watching the college and when
he got drafted and he does a lot
of great things in
the community so I just want to
get with
him and connect with him in
wheat black I stay with my
coach in Inglewood charges he
came out there and had
a conversation with my kids and
enlightening in the Chargers
blessing for uniform so this is
a real interactive thing that
we do with this youth
football we like people like him
because he still connected
to the community so that's how
we can make it up his family
that's reels know what it is and
cheating at this point in
your career what's it like to
have a quarterback like Herbert
about everybody's
making plays man any any Emmys
winning at the game on the back
side so that is amazing to have
a guy who can get it all done
with Sean slater man you got to
talk to me about this is
a rookie playing left tackle
he's playing
on the All-Pro level tell me
your thoughts on him he's
a rookie but if you came to
practice and watched you
wouldn't know it was a he works
like a like a Corey Linsley you
see Corey all the time getting
there working you'll see
Rayshawn over
there by self doing his own
thing in his work in doing that
too much he is so dedicated to
his craft and you can tell it
shows up on Sundays he doesn't
last too many sacks nobody get
to him on that side of the ball
so
so hats off the right time and
right now too so
y'all should be a threat that's
the main thing that Brandon
Staley done for you guys cuz you
mentioned earlier when
Austin ekeler was he talked
about them finishing instilling
the confidence that we got it
went when we know we not we
know what we used to
be we're not we're not there and
he took over that culture
and brought that energy that we
would have waited but We Dem
Boyz
can take to you know the Harvard
act like we don't pack
a punch on the great call I
don't pack Potter's full
halftime show halftime
show when is West Coast that is
furnished you understand me dr.
Dre has the general to this
bringing in Kendrick Lamar
Eminem mary-j-blige need to
bring his 1212 the deal double
G is West Coast to the fullest
content Long Beach La we going
to give it
to you like you never seen it
before and I'm thankful to
Rodrigo Dale and Jay Z and all
the people for letting hip hop
get on that stage at the
halftime show for the first
time you got a hip hop to play
the late they know
you're not crazy